hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again
today we're gonna be talking about
another new teaser that is just released
on the for honor Twitter this is
probably in regards to the newest event
coming in the next couple days or this
Thursday depending on the time that
you're watching said video be as always
like the V if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started with today's video so yeah this
was on the for honor Twitter just in
case you have not seen the video I'm
going to be playing the full video in
length right now and then we're gonna
talk about it afterwards also do be
aware of the quality this is a Twitter
video so the bigger this screen that I'm
going to make it the worse that's gonna
look at the more pixels you'll see so if
it looks shitty quality that's just how
to order videos have always been yeah
let me roll the video found the one fire
that could destroy all
and now these wolves have attacked my
home
trying to steal my discovery I will not
let these animals take
really me no choice
so yeah that was the video also I ended
up actually showing a YouTube video as
opposed to a Twitter video because as
soon as I was about to record this they
actually released the trailer on YouTube
and it does say for honor seasonal event
trailer so that's going to be it's
actually more of a teaser but once again
it is for the seasonal event so that
does confirm the suspicions once again
if you're not already caught up to date
on what's happening with this year's
events every single event throughout the
whole year of year 3 is going to be
talking about the lore of the characters
and kind of how they got there just kind
of spread that story a little bit and
this season is no exception and we're
gonna be talking at really about soon
dot and kind of how he came here what
his style is why he always talks about
fire and that's kind of his thing and
you know just the whole everything about
him if you want to know a little bit
more about soon die you can click at the
I in the top right that'll take you to a
lore video about who soon da really is
kind of as a real-life character and
then kind of what they're based off of
how they got to be and also the in-game
lore of who the character actually is I
believe the male version actually had to
decide whether to kill his parents or to
end up dying with his parents so I ended
up killing his parents and now he serves
the emperor yeah but that's really the
trailer as we could really piece
together there's not too much stuff it
looks like this is gonna be something in
terms of purple flames maybe a new emo
for the new event either way it looks
really cool there wasn't a lot talked
about obviously this is just a teaser
there's going to be a hell of a lot more
on the upcoming dev stream this Thursday
but as for what this is and what this is
doing we really don't know just yet I
still think this is going to be
something about a new game-mode with the
new breach map maybe a variation of
breach the minions might look different
which might also explain why the minions
also have the black stone Legion shield
so maybe that was a teaser for the event
after all we'll have to see when it
comes out but yeah let me know what you
guys think about this stuff in the
comments below like I said just a very
short video I just wanted to let you
guys see this and maybe share some
thoughts or in the comments yeah but I
was like the V if you're doing Joe
subscribe for new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes and the leaks
everybody kept those today with
everything happening to the world of
honor and never miss out on an update
deftly subscribe the channel and with
that guys take care have a great rest
today I'll see you guys on Thursday for
the four honor video
and peace out